okay two people joining the livestream
we are going to be talking about
polyhedra and new polyhedron
capabilities for version 12 of off
language so think we briefly covered
everything but the one thing that we
didn't quite drill into fully musti's
beveled polyhedra dual polyhedra and so
on no I'm not sure that we fully covered
let's just poke into some other stuff
for a minute okay though um so for
example a dodecahedron here okay so is
this analogous to what we did with with
the angles for regular polygons right
we've got a bunch of angle stuff right
and is that the same for the okay so
it's our theta and then the N for the
regular polygons so the polyhedron I see
in then it's an XY and R Spec right so
this is the same deal so I can say
dodecahedron that's nice so I can say
dodecahedron and then fate of Phi I
don't understand those coordinates what
are they all or angles or something else
no the spherical coordinates
the words if I want my my dodecahedron
to point to if I find for example geo
position I mean so first of all you can
use any way you want to sort of F
finally transform it you know if you
want to use Euler angle if you want to
use other things you can do it by
transformations but what's built-in are
these that are in the illustration which
are two standard spherical okay so this
particular thing
it's going to be a dodecahedron that has
been tipped to somehow have it's
something I don't know whether that's
tipped towards New Yorker away from New
York by making sense so it's given a geo
position this would be perhaps a useful
thing to have in properties in relations
here given a geo position right what is
it it's the junior position you find it
can be you example like that geo has a
weird choice of spherical as you know I
understand it's something I who knows
who decided that
let's decided a long time ago not by us
um but explain to me the relationship
between this so the physics at exactly
what it is there so if you know what geo
convention is you can relate it to that
right but is is Theta latitude is this
is this is lat/long and your theta phi
is what deliberately what the picture
yeah this song do you know which aspect
to the different plane axis so today is
a rotation with respect to the z axis on
pfizer to the west i see so they're
different things okay fine you know I
wonder whether I now roll pitch yaw and
all that kind of stuff is there a
conversion or am i confused between
those types of spherical coordinates and
the lat/long spherical coordinates and
so on where is that a stupid question
it's I don't know exactly what it is
that those both you know both of those
are thinking that you're doing a
rotation a sequence of three rotations
the only difference between the two of
them is that one is you keep the frame
the rotated frame so oiler keeps the
rotated frame and rotates in that new
frame the the the other one keeps a
fixed frame and rotates within the fixed
frame and there are 12 in each the 12
conventions in each okay all right fine
okay
hey pyramid why doesn't it have an
arbitrary base why doesn't have a
polygonal base because the the these
were introduced for finite elements and
these are bridging elements that have
been needed so you see this a future ice
thing to allow for an arbitrary base but
it's not there yet why is it that the
base is what why are you flattening that
list why don't have the base be a
separate might not have the the list of
base points together with um we can't
change it right now Steven just it's not
you know these were as I said for finite
elements you have hexahedral and you
have tetrahedra if you have a mixed mesh
you need bridging elements and are to
bridging elements one of them is pyramid
and one of them is how is it called
scroll down and you see also some prison
yes okay so listen I would like to
record that I think this design is
slightly wrong I think this should be
the list of base points together with
the and then they the apex point not a
big deal but I think it's wrong and it's
not incompatible with this hey you're
doing sorry again
yeah I don't disagree with you I I think
you okay so we couldn't we couldn't
absolutely not support it at the time
and this was no problem okay I'm just
who's gonna make a note of that you know
whoever wants to make notes I make it
not where we who is here okay yeah okay
great
we would come to this anyway Steven okay
you
yeah that's rather unfortunate okay so
that's another not wonderful thing okay
fine no sir yeah
is this new parallelepiped no no okay
all right fine but it's a polyhedron
yeah I understand
so so in this case what's new here
Steven is is the the five platonic
solids have their names okay one you
know two of them had it before like a
tetrahedron and hexahedron the other
ones are new okay you've already looked
at this okay so okay all right okay okay
this work does this work now random
polyhedron well we couldn't you just
have a case for convex hull we are
working on the generator for sample and
convex so so if I just give that though
so currently she do in at least convex
hull comma 10 so essentially we generate
10 point handily on the Q bond generator
convexity
okay so what are we doing I mean are you
going to get this in time because this
is still future eyes here we think so
okay fine so then this will default we
might be a little bit limited
functionality fire but but the default
case with n faces does that have an
obvious meaning I mean don't you have to
say how many of each guy to face you
don't you have to say this is a I want a
you know a random thing with with
triangular faces and so on well you
don't have to but these are infinitely
stretchable in terms of what is it that
what aspect of this do you want to
specify and we will have some models now
and that can be expanded over time
because there may be some certain
classes that are particularly
interesting to generate like for
instance let's say that you wanted to
have triangular faces yeah I just don't
want to make sure that the specification
we have doesn't doesn't mess us up with
respect to that I don't think it does I
think spec is very general okay okay
question on our live stream how is is a
degenerate construct two or several
connected polyhedra I think that's where
you're using graphics complex is that
right or not what was the question two
or more connected polyhedra
well they where the vertices of one
polyhedron presumably are coincident
with vs. or another well that there's
several ways to do that you can if you
just model graphics you can use graphics
complex mesh mesh region boundary mesh
region do that you can do it
polyhedron you can do it with polygons
but so if I take this polyhedron for
example right and I want to have how
would I take that polyhedron and like
like come make a copy of it you know
reflected in that point for example that
easy to do well then you have to
probably use a reflection transform you
know what that point is you're a
reflection transform you have to get the
data out what it is you want to do I
know so let's do first a polyhedron now
I assume that the okay so there I've got
a point so now what do i do i do comma
and no reflection transform will
generate to transform it doesn't take
any objects okay so look at what reflect
you know look up the definition I don't
know what the definition is sort of even
though I wrote it normal to that vector
well okay fair enough actually so let's
actually take a different thing let's
take a trance a translation transform or
is it just translate translation
transform of let's say you can actually
translate would work directly on the
object so okay fine fine let's just do
that translate the polyhedron by let's
say 1 1 1 ok now I
want to combine that with the original
polyhedron how do I do that
graphically no not graphics I want to I
want to get the outer polyhedron of that
combined thing that's called Regent
Union right what do you mean by outer
what do you mean by outer well we'll
decide on that in a minute
so translates not yet will come fully at
home I'm sorry what doesn't what
translate doesn't work on polyhedron
we haven't yet implemented you'll be
implemented so can I use translation
transform no they all fall in the same
family okay all right so this isn't
gonna work basically well I could just
do that with a dodecahedron
that's probably similarly not in
lamented gusto decay torn is a
polyhedron no I didn't mean that I meant
I meant this okay what did that just do
so that made okay so now now I could say
graphics 3d of that why is that
polyhedron got a bunch of points in it
why does it not come out with a with a
is it buggin if typesetting on fixing
okay all right fine
so there's that and now if I were to
make the dodecahedron how do I make the
dodecahedron smaller I'd say 0.5 huh yes
okay beautiful okay um okay so now now
when I take this thing here I can do I
should be able to do outer polyhedron of
that right is that correct outer what oh
yeah right and then I can make graphics
3d of that and I should see
some kind of okay what did that just do
that that just made oh I see it if I now
say convex hull of that what will I get
then I'll get then I'll get something
different right yes you will get the
convex hull that is not yet implemented
but you could just do it with a pointy
will get what you looking for
so I could say polyhedron coordinates
yes okay okay all right so down here I
don't even know what this is what is
this we looked at this last time but
this is polygon but you know you're now
going to have a polyhedron version of
this is that correct right this examples
are wrong but you are uncrossing
polyhedron right examples are not
yeah the examples oh okay I see so if I
were to do that polyhedron decomposition
for this guy it's not yet implemented
okay but in principle this would then
decompose this into those pieces yeah
yeah so you pick actually try that one
that should probably work the result of
the Union
Wow okay what did it just do that so
it's essentially decomposed them in the
union of the Titans okay is that its
default currently yes but the publish
shouldn't be the default what okay all
right but that was impressive what it
did that so if I say graphics 3d of that
I should get back the original thing yes
except that it's full of full of um
tetrahedron seams on it
beautiful okay but so the default will
be simple polyhedra um yes if you manage
to have it before the release but
otherwise what's it gonna be this should
not be a non experimental function if it
isn't the final form like we make turn
it into experimentally fees but it could
also be that its final form except not
all the layers are there yet I'm saying
yeah I know but I understand but then
then you would have to get rid of the
default you know that one argument case
probably now right okay so is this one
an arbitrary what are those things
roughly symbols or something yes all
these three names so I don't even know
what is it I mean so if I do polyhedron
data of you know our rhombic hexahedron
for example that's producing a piece of
graphics right so how do I get the
analogous polyhedron object from that
just use the same string if is a regular
polyhedron it gives you two
what does what does it mean well you so
polyhedron data uniform em polyhedron
data has 22 out of 75 uniform polyhedra
so we completing that up okay but what
does polyhedron data contains other
miscellaneous things yeah it doesn't fit
anywhere you know like I mean they're
not unuseful but I'm just saying it's a
it's a kind of a it's not okay so how
are we going to merge these pieces of
functionality you so polyhedron data
should generate you can't merge them
first of all because it's not clean you
know that it can be a sort of room for
something that's an arbitrary collection
like graph data is kind of an arbitrary
collection or graph and a fan I'm asking
I'm asking it's not compatible to have I
mean if this says you know so what we
propose to do that it will actually
generate a region of polyhedron it's the
standard output data yes
that's gonna break a lot of things
because a lot of people will be assuming
it's generating graphics but then we
can't change it then it will generate
graphics and it can I know I know so
rich Roger and not not being this
function it's probably going to be some
other function so let's talk about that
so we have a proposal if you offend the
prototype build at least if it's recent
we have a proposal we work with very
conduct are essentially Polly on data
will return a region which automatically
or to visualize let's take a look at
that
cube what's doing now that's computable
yeah I understand
you know we're graphics I'm wondering
I'm wondering whether what we should do
because polyhedron data hmm and if you
apply show to it it turns it into
graphics just do show of that no it
doesn't well it's not the default
graphics I mean you haven't removed
Iqaluit I mean do styling see if you
want us to just use the default light on
or move all do color on the face yeah
but okay but hold on but I mean if we
look at one of these so I agree there's
a bunch of garbage well not garbage but
just weird stuff here right weird named
objects right so but it also has um you
know there's also a lot of properties of
this thing right yes but the lord of
those properties at the time that was
the only way to record and to store them
compute them record them but what are
these things are now functions that you
do to him saying yeah well like regent
function is that really a that's a way
to encode it as its predicate I know
okay so something like that hmm
now presumably we could support that for
arbitrary polyhedra yes yes yes
so let's take a look at the properties
because I mean then then in a sense what
you're saying is for some of these
things we could just have you generate
the polyhedron as a region and then you
compute these things on it right but
this would for example would be a nice
function to have wouldn't it for a you
know a polyhedron skeleton or something
would be a reasonable function to have
if I'm not mistaken yeah yeah I mean but
their varying sort of in their
applicability like who wants to order
stamp collectors that want them or do do
they have real purpose I think this
particular one is quite useful to be
able to get a graph out of the
polyhedron sure but we'll have many
graph things coming you know it's it's
mesh and polyhedron boundary mash and
polyhedron it's sort of the same thing
just one is richer the boundary mesh
region is sort of richer in a second we
get graphs out of boundary meshes we
will document the whole slew of them
there's a whole slew of them coming okay
all right but but so okay so listen we
have to talk about how to get compatible
let's say here okay because we've got I
mean we've got these two things and so
right now even in the one that runs in
in master you can get mesh you know if
you're specified as a property pick
called mesh and that would be the way
that in 11 3 and older you would get
sort of a computable thing okay but
you're saying polyhedron data of the
rhombic whatever it is comma mesh forget
what it's called a mesh region okay mesh
region mr. John wonderful miss Mitchell
yeah that's a mesh region boundary mesh
readings really oh why did that jump in
terms of size with the why did they part
of the UM rotation make it jump because
it's it's probably does a you know I
know why it makes a snug fit will you
stop that's no no no no this is a bug
associated with the with the bounding
box I thought that have now been fixed
Charles you're aware of that okay this
is a this is something you should Matt
maybe you could take this
we send it to you give it to you sue I
think it's a bug in the way that the
rotation controller thing works okay
right my guess is that what's happening
is that when I pick it up I know exactly
what's happening it's getting the
bounding box and then it computes the
minimum sphere outside of that bounding
box that's why it jumps right but but
but that the min ball of this thing is
exactly the right thing this is not in
ball deals with points but it can deal
with this thing - it did what do -
implements is a way to specify the
rotation to have a sphere which we can
compute when we generated like I
understand but that that the sphere for
this thing the min ball for this thing
is I don't know if it's yet implement
that is it yet implement well that's the
question I think it's a bug and I said
no it's not implemented it's like no bug
it's not useless
it is but you said builds the mechanism
where if he can you know because he it
doesn't mean he can compute the bounding
sphere for any kind of scene you know it
just means that we have to regenerate
all this Moyer to regenerate all of them
- do you know where we computed that
that remember okay and feed it you know
listen polyhedral data we need to talk
about okay but let's go on with what we
what we have here okay um now the thing
that you pointed out which we didn't
spend enough time on or the polyhedron
operations dual polyhedron augmented
polyhedron little polyhedron truncated
polyhedron snub poly turns those five
okay fine let's take a look at those
okay so let's say we didn't look at them
at all I think we did you looked at
briefly at them but we didn't spend any
serious time so we okay all right let's
take a look at some of these okay so now
I take a random polyhedron and well
first of all let's take a look at dual
polyhedron okay so if I say dodecahedron
and I say dual polyhedron of that I
should get an icosahedron if I'm not
mistaken
fascinating
that's cool that's kind of cool actually
so if I were to say a dodecahedron of
size 2 PI over 4 PI over 2 for example
humph
what happened there I know he's to come
up I ever [ __ ] he used to have to be
inside your list this one here no it
should be over just the R&D talk to
uncle so you have to put two in see no
default PI over 4
radius and what if you remove the next
bracket R Theta Phi yes
that's pretty neat
ok that's pretty neat alright I think I
understand that one another thing I
should notice about this particularly
you have to realize that in principle
you want to apply this to everything but
those constructs are not well defined so
we're gonna refine that post-test
version so that the dual thing is not
well I mean if I were to take but if I
take this thing here for example hmm um
I mean that is perfectly well defined do
all right well well for this case that
that's that's okay
magnificent yeah so you can compute
things like the dual of a bunny or
something like that if you have a
polyhedron bunny or polyhedron airplane
you know how do I get one of those yeah
oh come on what does that do what is
what - are you asking for oh and I will
tell you what you can specify next
yeah but why it's taking why it's
downloading everything I have no idea
that seems wrong and by the way now this
is the thing for you to try and figure
out how we can use Nix caching
infrastructure for for entity properties
stuff to deal with this as well to do
with example data and/or possibly
something for the resource I mean maybe
this should just hook into the resource
system now seems like a reasonable way
to do it I mean if you look at the busy
sample there is the on twelve pontiff is
an example he wants on dual polyhedron
if you look at the basic example Steven
yeah okay let me just do this because
I'm just going to get but these four I
don't know how well form these are we'll
see okay I don't know if they have full
of defects or is it closed for instance
how do I get the mesh for this
come on mesh region so which cover a
boundary mesh region but not much the
mesh region okay so if I say dual
polyhedron of that probably cannot come
you know beautiful yet or not of it
probably have holes or defective are
lapping faces okay so if you take the
space shuttle I think that one is close
alright well I'm okay
so you're saying what what should I look
at here in the basic example is such so
we took the space shuttle from the
example data we convert it to a fully
aired on and you can compute one out of
it great that still looks like a space
shuttle isn't that amazing
to do all space shuttle is a sub special
right there's probably some fascinating
fact about fluid dynamics no I'm not I
mean that's just because okay let's take
a look at some of these others okay
augmented polyhedron so this is what
we'd usually be cool stellated yes
what's the difference installation
augmented and we've called these
stellated for thirty years so it's if
we're really gonna change that to
augment it what what is augmented mean I
mean the real name people use is
augmented I mean the only time actually
find it was now up full yet fully on
operation we call it steli shtetl 800
what is this solitude dodecahedron
that's that's a thing right right
Vitelli stellated icosahedron is most
definitely a thing right
okay so this is a what wikipedia says
about still Asian stelazine polyhedra
what is this operation is this different
right so so the mighty domain typo later
on actually z' is kind of a special case
of that because here we are mounting the
face so we are just you know adding it
pyramid on top of each face yes okay but
so what's the general case here in what
sense I mean this is kind of the most
common operation people use so we fill
that one I understand well in terms of
naming it happens to be that we've used
still Asian to represent this for a long
time so it seems unfortunate to call it
augmented when nobody's gonna know what
that is in our particular you know and
if there's some way of defining this to
be you know scalation which we can then
add to at some point and have different
kinds of still Asian that would be a
good thing right I think we should call
it stellated unless there's a really
good reason not to
there seems to be a perfectly good
notion of stellated which produces the
effect we want is there a problem with
that no no I agree with that
okay fine it says is also known as
delighted okay so fine let's just call
it started by Hedra and we'll say it's
also known as an Augmented polyhedron
um now in what what height of pyramid
what is that height that the height
parameter what is that um so if I say
um dodecahedron and and what is the
height parameter that we're using there
okay well it just says a pyramid of
height H so it's that in absolute
coordinates or what or is it relative to
the size of the polyhedron if everything
was collected to the sensor to put it on
doesn't it seem right to me seems like
it should be it should be what we should
do is to have something where you can
say scaled of something or other to make
it relative to the height making sense I
mean in other words so it's relative to
the heart I think you are using a
quarter what really we are using a scale
scale system Souls I mean if in your
example if you don't mind it comma or
0.25 I don't understand that so what's
the default each face by pyramid of that
size why is that the default but does
the most common value be found that
people use okay like in here for example
so I think you should say okay so but it
is that size relative so what if it's an
irregular polyhedron for example like
this thing here how does it how does it
then decide what that H parameter is oh
we use the same value no doesn't make
sense
what do you mean by that is it relative
to the two unit length in the is it in
absolute coordinates that's what I'm
trying to understand
well I there's a number of these and I
kind of have a feeling that we need both
scaled and absolute that's what I think
we do too I think I need that right so
that's why I'm suggesting that we use
scaled to represent the scaled case and
that scale has to do we have to define
what its scale with respect to exactly
them like the men ball size or something
right
so I mean I'm trying to think that we
can do that sort of different scale so
if you only look in the world of uniform
polyhedra often edge length is something
that you want to use it so D right so
this scale we use here is to do height
what do you mean by width the height
what is this height is that you call the
edge length height exactly but that but
what's the edge length of this weird you
know
non non regular polyhedron they're
different lengths
yeah there are many different lengths
here so what's the edge length fear I
mean personally I think it makes more
sense to have the default be absolute
coordinate size right absolute distance
in the coordinate system that these
things are defined in which by the way
is going to be the same because the you
know the the regular polyhedra
presumably are defined with with unit
edge length right well it sees what I'm
saying yes it's so we take do
essentially we have the period on we say
a you know a quarter high essentially
that means from the face I think no no
Charles I think that that parameter and
it's there's a few other ones too I
think what we should do is that's an
eighth speck okay there's a table of
ways that you can specify it they can be
scaled they can be absolute you know and
that gives you enough flexibility right
I think the absolute to be clear what we
mean by absolute in the coordinate
system where these are the absolute
coordinate XYZ values right absolute
means you know square root of x square
plus y square plus Z squared equals
whatever it equals right right right
Charles yes
and thus collect is what we do right now
it's what I mean okay well so I think
okay of absolute so this means of
absolute height H right can I say this
of absolute height don't modify it now
Steven we we need to add a section air
that talks about okay no it's gonna be
similar things for the other ones okay
okay all right okay so then what we've
agreed then is that you support
something which says scaled and and how
would scaled work it could be scaled or
it can be a list string come or
something because it could be more we
could need something you know let's say
that we support scaled and make that an
interpretation that we describe but then
we need something else that's also
practical value all right fine that's
fine so let's do scaled relative to the
men ball or something else that you
specify makes sense right okay um you
know by the way I'm not really keen on
this takes the same options as I think
we really do need to explode these but
that's a that's a separate issue um okay
so that's okay so that's gonna be
stellated um okay beveled bevels the
edges by length ratio at its edges so
what is length so that's then a scaled
ratio that's what I mean with all these
parameters I think we need to expand
that parameter case for all of them to
give this you know more legs it's
flexible so so what does it mean to
bevel I don't what is bevel in any way
really we're beveling is when you round
off an edge okay so what is the beveling
parameter here in the default case with
one argument is a guinea quadrant
okay well we should obviously say that
somewhere here yes okay so then if we're
gonna say beveled let's say 0.5 here
I did the wrong thing did I do the wrong
thing ah yes I did the wrong thing here
also the default is 1/4 so let's see
what that looks like
oops
okay now what and it's beautiful what
happens if I if I nested lis bubble
something continues to bevel okay but I
mean if I say double polyhedron you
might take something simple to start
with a cube or something that's yeah no
okay
yeah cube we do we have cube don't we
have cube no why not doesn't that seem
inconsistent that we don't have cube
well we had cuboid so I understand but I
think listen I think people are gonna be
super confused if we don't you will add
cube why don't we add cube what's the
ordering that we have here well we
should put the the look we should put in
this list we should just put the pot
Platonic solids in order that reunion
cube octahedron etc and then have a
separate line for these other ones yes
make sense yes okay oh boy this kind of
take forever okay so then I say I would
map graphics over it not look yeah
that's rather elegant that's really
quite nice very nice
well there's some bug here by the way
with selection that's spectacular
okay um okay truncated that chops off
the corners truncates the corners okay
so if I do that here this will again
make it so again is it always using a
quarter as the yeah okay
it's nice this is really nice
okay what is a snub those filming and
truncating that's gonna be oh okay is
that regular why isn't that more regular
why doesn't that look regular because
there is no CC both Beverly on location
so we is it possibly willing so half of
this vertex
how do you pick which one is which just
based on the hot wing they're not
precise scheme for the selection hold on
hold on I want to understand this okay
hold on so I mean a snub cube like this
thing here right we've heard of a snub
cube and a snub cube I don't understand
this no I don't understand I don't
understand how you got that irregular
thing there this doesn't seem right to
me
it doesn't isn't a snub cube of thing
yes and that's regular there see
whereas this isn't regular I will check
if is this immigration you know check
I'm suspicious here I'm suspicious that
the snub polyhedron thing isn't
well-defined
well it doesn't commute in which order
you do things so you know in general no
I realize that I realized that but this
is saying this says by truncating some
corners it didn't way met generates
polygons obtained by beveling edges and
truncating vertices hmm I think there's
something wrong here I mean if we had to
drop snub polyhedron for this version
and worry about it later I think there
wouldn't be a disaster but it doesn't
look right something is obviously gone
wrong here
yes there's also a lot of other ones
that you can build which are basically
one you know two combinations of two
that have names in some smaller not as
heavily used but they why aren't we just
letting people just compose the
functions that's what we do we don't
introduce in so there are application
examples okay okay but I mean snubbing
so to speak seems to be okay fine by the
way if I say if I take one of these
things with there ten more of these
Stephen so or dozen more of what of
combining two of the ones we have I say
but but they may it may not be worth
giving them names that's that was our
call yes yeah okay
something seems to have gone wrong there
you see that
yeah it's chose what's the story with
this one I said what you on that which
aspect of it essentially we need to
propagate or support for the other one
on alt no 12 to whole genetic
nationality so I say okay okay so it's
just not ready yet for a moment of
inertia yes okay okay so if I would say
for example of this thing here just I
would just to say polyhedron genus why
didn't that work
why didn't that work
starting already yet um can you actually
apply colors on this one yeah yes what
should I call it canonicalize canonical
collegian right so he's probably worried
we shouldn't have to do that but still
didn't work yes well here I'll save this
file
okay do you think volume will work on
this thing actually volume is it surface
area or what volume is volume
okay so volume is the enclosed volume
yeah didn't work okay well so something
is wrong here
okay all right let's just do one more
pass here okay so the things that we're
still flagging is Asuza the polyhedron
data case just the name of augmented
polyhedron the scaling of the edges the
snubbing whatever that is I I would
recommend just removing snub for right
now if it isn't clear how its defined
make sense - yeah um now in the case
with polyhedrons with holes and things I
mean there are all these operations well
defined these operations get we don't
know exactly the range of when they are
defined I mean this operation I
generally define just for basic regular
for the item that's actually do
mathematical concepts yeah as soon as
generally is an arbitrary polyhedron you
won't work you'll have intersection I
mean not generalize so the hope is that
maybe we can correct those resulting
operation by doing boolean operation at
the end to recover them but probably not
for this release yeah I understand
that's fine
so just fail in some dignified way um
okay let's go back to polyhedron edge
actually a couple of questions on our
live stream here
um Ali says um creating sheets of
biological cells and 3d and applying
forces to vertices that sounds like a
use of of our meshing technology on same
note how easy would be to construct two
or several connected polyhedra
polyhedral form one unit
I think that's region Union isn't it
combined polyhedron sad but it but but
also in the very definition of
polyhedron you can do that directly
there okay reagent union is if you get
sort of two polyhedra in the wild and
you wanna this one one way of combining
it's a union but the basic definition of
polyhedron uses a graphics complex like
notation so you shared a coordinate data
and then you just provided topology data
you know oh yeah so I think the answer
happily is it is possible to do this
combined polyhedra into a sheet so to
apply forces diversities that should
work you should be able to take this
thing um you should be able to take
those polyhedra and basically just take
their graphs combine the graphs and feed
the geometry into it um writing some
indices in digital polyhedron labels and
the points corresponding to the
polyhedron index I think that's what
we're just talking about if it's not let
us know um okay let's go back to
polyhedron data um okay so what can we
do there I mean what we have in
polyhedron data is lots of random
properties like nets and things right
which are not I mean I doubt we're um um
I don't like the fact that polyhedron
data I mean what can we do well there
will be new properties that gives you
more output forms now the question is
what the default is so minimal thing is
to add more properties so you can get
the polyhedron huh so here's a question
what if we had a function called regular
polyhedron does that not make any sense
what is that term what would that we
thought but it was very few okay that's
why we went to uniform which is a richer
class
what does regular mean it's it's
Platonic and Archimedean right it's it's
roughly choice you remember what is it's
a good we could somebody try to get Eric
questions if he's available in a regular
polygon is one which have a set of
vertices so its vertex its 1 is positive
at the end you end up just having 75 of
them plus an infinite form to infinite
family be placed one Nancy please well
that the same numbers uniform no sorry I
was talking about the uniform so I know
the regular one yeah you end up with a
platonic solid right yeah yeah you also
have the for stop for your cloud and I
mean certainly Wikipedia's comments on
this it has a very generalized notion of
what it means by regular polyhedron
let's get Eric see what he has to say
about this I have a feeling that it
would be less obscure for people if we
call it regular polyhedron and then
because we're gonna feed in all kinds of
stuff there right but there's just nine
fill up for you no that's not true it's
not true it depends what you mean by
regular polyhedron sure I mean for
example if you look on this page right
this is well okay so those are those
ones and then the claim is
generalizations okay
not regular anymore unregular let's ask
Eric what he has to say about this he
may yet agree with you okay um I mean
you know the issue is what you've got so
what are the uniform polyhedra that
they're that the reference page is not
complete they're 75 of them okay but
I'll be specified by names or the
specified by some kind of firm slothy
index or something but okay so what is
this roughly index like six seven or
something because that'll [ __ ] Almighty
for example okay that's cube but what
happens if I say four comma three halves
so we haven't yet finished gently
mendl's which are the star ones okay
okay but so in what sense can you just
transfer these over to polyhedron data
that is we already have the information
of polyhedron data no these are not yet
in polyhedron data so it's the other way
around once Charlson Roger and Friends
have beautifully implemented it I will
make sure it goes into polyhedron data
okay all Stephen the okay um what we are
talking about is the chorus okay let's
ask a few questions
the term regular polyhedron is that in
any way generalized relative to the
Kepler past so verse and platonic or is
that just the nine polyhedra represented
there nodes if we wanted to call instead
of calling a uniform polyhedron which i
think is hard to understand for people
if we call that regular polyhedron we'll
be confused people could we general yes
you will confuse people uniform
polyhedron should stay uniform
polyhedron regular generally includes
Kepler and Kepler poncy and platonic
right okay you might be amused even but
I went down exactly your path okay I'm
not surprised
okay okay question then Eric um
so we're trying to understand for
polyhedron data what stuff is in
polyhedron data that is not supported I
mean things like the skeleton of the
polyhedron and there's a whole bunch of
other stuff like nets and so on right
which are basically hand curated because
we don't have a way to unfold polyhedra
and things like that
they're not algorithmic most of the
things that are in polyhedron data okay
so the real issue is the polyhedron data
I mean for example our rhombic x2 canto
he drew is not a uniform polyhedron
apparently but true statement or is that
not a true statement it's true okay so
what other families are there when we go
from the regular polyhedra to the
uniform polyhedra is there other other
families that are obvious and well-known
Johnson which are the ones that are
convex with regular faces okay but I
mean it's that that's about it though
besides the infinite families like
prisms and anti prisms and all those
guys which we're getting in a different
way here is that correct the prism thing
here we would get we will be able to
just specify prism of I mean presumably
eventually we'll be able to say prism of
regular poly polygon of black on a block
whatever probably not prism is a graphic
Linnet even if the syntax is different
from an end prism what does that mean
look look it's a rough guide page for it
so that's an arbitrary prism not of I
see I see a prison with a polygonal base
and then an apex well so are we then
saying we want sort of prism polyhedron
or something that's the thing which is
an extruded polyhedron extruded polygons
well if you want the regular ones you
could just perhaps overload prism with
prism of integer or prism of integer
with a list of base it's not clear to me
you need a different symbol but that's
no well no but but you need just be able
to you need like these other things you
need to be able to say where it's
centered and all that kind of stuff
right the currently implemented one is
the most general you want one that
somehow a little bit less general but
most currently reminder prism is the
most general yes I know it right but I'm
saying but but then you also have in
polygon polyhedron data right you have a
something-or-other prism right I don't
know what can I ask pentagonal prism or
something yeah those are very special
ones though those are ones that have
unit edge links and regular basis just
it's not the one you wanted but it's
pretty sorry it won't work dew prism in
a list string with comma five okay
you have tolerated child learning to
play some musical instrument uh it's not
too bad it's my daughter
but um it's okay anyway they um how do
you determine how tall this is oh it's
unit I view it's unit so it's centered
about plus or minus 1/2 see ya okay what
are we gonna do about the correspondence
between the fact that polyhedron data is
returning graphics and the fact that we
want uh I mean another possibility would
be to have a thing called named
polyhedron how crazy would that be well
to generalize to not have uniform
polyhedron but to have a named
polyhedron that has in it more more junk
I wouldn't say junk really but but um
this entity isn't it it's just syntactic
sugar fur
okay well let's talk about that for a
second it just Rogers does your stuff
support that if I say dodecahedron okay
that's an interesting idea that I just
say dodecahedron here and then could I
say something like you know for example
what would happen if I just were to say
that's an eternal integral polyhedra
know that this is that implement the
truth no well I think if you asked for
the property polyhedron or region or
whatever it will now this is a good idea
Erik this is the right way to do this
but this is this is bland we we started
to do that for couple weddings just
should require huge amount of effort why
does it require so much effort because
you have to support it for every
function or canonicalize correctly yeah
okay fine very bit but then then okay so
this is the answer to what we should do
here this is the answer this is what we
how we should do this because the one
thing you won't get
this way is parametrization of these
entities at least four simple parameters
not for arbitrary parameters so for
integer indices you can still make it
work because that's all that's in
polyhedron data there's nothing about
where the center is or oriented that's
what I mean I mean you can't do that so
you'd have to put that as an outer
wrapper but that's the right solution I
think here too rather than emphasizing
polyhedron data I think Steven if you if
you say entity polygon prism in vertex
count it will work but look if I say
okay prism but I mean something like
this yeah okay that's beautiful so like
the other star data functions we could
imagine retiring polyhedron data in
favor of entity property look up it's
not true it's true but you lose certain
stuff because the entity framework
basically is a bit of a straightjacket
what do you lose let's take a look at
what you lose you lose you you have to
spin for this sort of annotation
property which is a little non-standard
for a packet where you say what form you
want the output in that has to be done
now as what is it called in property
attribute yeah okay so what where do you
want that I mean where's that showing up
well so if you say polyhedron data cube
edges and then you can give a third
annotation that says I want the edges as
line or I want the edges as indices okay
well we have that in the entity property
yeah I'm just saying after we plummet as
a property attribute and there's some
other undocumented stuff that lets you
actually get different orientations of
polyhedra that are in the packet that
you'd have to figure out how to force
into the entity world right but I think
that's the right way to do that is with
an outer wrapper is to first get the
canonical orientation and then rotate it
I don't think we want that source to do
that I mean that that just is
very complicated now I mean this type of
thing like polyhedron you know that
these types of things don't do that in
the energy world using implicit entities
yes right well I think that's where we
should go
Roger did I mean that polyhedron data
should be on its way towards retirement
and replaced by entity stuff and that
Charles should simply support having you
know support entities here
and that's beautiful well that's our
plan I just don't know where do we well
that's fine I mean I don't care if it
yeah if it isn't you know solved right
I'd still think that we should have
uniform polyhedron i sir no I think
that's right I don't see a problem yeah
yep I don't see any problem with that um
let's just look at uniform polyhedron
and what it does name so there's no one
argument the uniform polyhedron of a
single n is there an obvious platonic
like story with that no what are the two
parameters here mean does the chef is
not this assembles right yeah but don't
they don't they mean something in terms
edges and faces um yes
what are they solo and sides with it to
each face on em face is missing at each
vertex right okay that's okay
okay so one day are we gonna end up with
with four-dimensional versions of this
and things with triples yeah I mean our
goal is to have polytopes said what you
mean yes okay so so it's a simple level
now polyhedron works you can have a
polyhedron in dimension for the same
beautiful I mean you can imagine a
uniform polyhedra and no no I I
understand what you're saying yeah it's
not urgent I think it's more important
to get really good in dimension two and
three of course I agree oh well I'm
gonna make a picky point that that
should be um ah fault different font
alright I think this is great Eric have
you looked at what these
have done with beveling and all that
kind of stuff and yet okay and they have
a parameter 1/4 which you may or may not
believe in which is the default relative
to the side length 1
the default stelae ssin brandings do you
don't have a concern about what the
default is I usually want to specify it
by hand okay um okay well I think this
is all magnificent so and I think I'm
pretty happy with the direction we're
going with polyhedron data think that's
fine I mean won't happen in this version
but I think that will happen in future I
think some thought about prism and
things would be good it was under on
that it's just not 4:12 okay yeah okay
wonderful
anything else we need to go home with as
Charles did you discuss the changing
outputs for polyhedron data yet yeah the
answer is we shouldn't do it we should
not do it we should not do it I don't
think I assumed we region but you just
don't want it for the one art form oh
for region you can do whatever you want
yes
but the one art form we've just got tons
of people who will have used by hidden
data you know for endless yep that's a
perfectly valid argument the other
argument in the other direction is that
we had the same situation for a graph
for graphs that were returning graph
plots and when we had the beautiful new
built-in object we started returning
that by the other the problem is well
unless we can make okay so one question
for Charles you know that the ghostly
blue thing right you're returning that
because you want it to seem more
computational than the graphics 3d
doesn't tell so we have a lot of very
fancy ways of displaying polyhedra which
people will enjoy a lot and we
pick something that you know and you
know part of what you kind of want to
emphasize here probably the edges and
stuff to get yes but I mean wait wait so
let's let's okay hold on one second so I
actually think we really need to just
support I mean does polyhedron data
support graphics graphics options no oh
so the thing you get by default is just
whatever we felt like giving you from
Grant yeah that's why you there's a
graphics complex property that you can
get if you want to wrap your own things
around it to put styling where you want
it and things like that okay so in other
words this is just a picture basically
the default graphics 3d with the
graphics complex inside well okay I
might be changing my mind here because
because so long as you can make it look
visually essentially the same I think
we're okay but the ghostly blue is not
gonna cut it explain why the ghostly
blue is the default it's just a default
for all of our sort of reach there's
nothing extra put into the thing that
generates it from polyhedra data but we
can't it's set up you said you can't you
can put in something extra we can yes it
was just not done it was just all the
tease stock settings at this point okay
there is one subtlety though which is
that the polyhedron property will return
a polyhedron object which does not
format by default
whereas graph graph objects do format by
default yeah listen listen look before
this version let's not mess with I I
think that's reasonable so let's have a
polyhedron property that will return the
polyhedron object but the default one
art will be graphics 3d still and then
exactly and the goal will be in the
future to basically retire polyhedron
data in favor of entities just like
we're doing in many other places okay
then you get around the backward in
compatibility by deprecating the whole
shebang kind of yes I mean it'll
continue to work but but it won't be the
the preferred mechanism
okay so in other words if I take
polyhedron day to prison five and I say
of polyhedron here by the way this isn't
no no you'd have to do that in the
entity world so entity polyhedron prison
five whoa does that work oh I didn't
even know that worked no I guess I
didn't know that work yes it doesn't
work well but that's because the pr to
make it work is waiting up this
discussion okay it works in sources that
are not yet merged okay okay fine fine
fine fine okay um okay it's wonderful
very very nice stuff okay I didn't
commit anything here right Roger so I'm
not gonna push my my that's good that's
it you still have a few passes as you
can tell yep it's really beautiful it's
really and I really like this bastard
don't you yeah don't you love the Ness
to do I like those wonderful yeah um
when do we get extrusion and things like
that for just general regions what does
that not even make sense
no it makes sense but it's complicated
and what we needed to do was to not
generate extrusions which you can what
we didn't want to do we needed to
strengthen the core framework quite
substantially and was part of what we've
been focusing on and doing smaller sort
of build our projects at the same time
if we just do build-out and nothing
works it will be kind of disappointing
yeah okay hey I should go but actually
one more question for Eric snob
polyhedra we seem to have some
incompatibility in the definition of
those do you understand what those
should be what is the incompatibility is
it oriental no look snob cube looks like
this it's a very regular object yeah
snubbing by best snub polyhedron
operation produces an irregular object
you need a certain value of that snub
efficacious ratio probably to get the
regular one okay and but that will will
vary with the polyhedron oh yes so is
there an obvious default that can be
used that will you'd have to
on the object you were sniffing which is
a little overly complicated but is there
not a parameter I mean if it's a regular
poly if it's a uniform polyhedron is
there a is there a snubber fication
parameter that could be derived for any
regular polyhedron I'm not sure look at
that number fide snubber for I guessed
one half and it worked okay so one
quarter gives that gives a skewed result
but one half is correct in this case
right that 1/4 is that result charles
etc they don't look quite the same no no
so here but if I now say dodecahedron
the um is that now correct for one half
or is that wrong is there a snub
dodecahedron I believe so
you can just do as a string snub with
the star and at all yeah
well what do you know I mean it depends
normalized you might be able to
normalize them by circumradius instead
of edge length and have one
simplification ratio that would look it
looks to me like summer vacation ratio
of 1/2 for our edge length 1 polyhedra
is just working I can check but it could
be okay all right well let's check that
but we're probably gonna leave snub out
of this this sum this version unless
there's some obvious way to do it
snubbing where the half seems to be
doing the right thing here though okay I
mean yeah okay all right see you guys
soon